make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and in
today's beyond omega-level video we are
focusing on a character that has gone
through a number of changes to both her
origin and power level but one that when
operating at her highest level is an
incredibly powerful character in this
video we're talking about Wanda Maximoff
The Scarlet Witch so before we discuss
her powers and feats we'll go over her
origin which is pretty convoluted as
it's been retconned on multiple
occasions but probably the only aspect
of scarlet witch's origin this remain
consistent is that she was created by
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby now Miss messing
around she was created by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby and first appeared in x-men
number four in 1964 as a member of
Magneto's Brotherhood of Evil Mutants
she later leave the group before
eventually joining the Avengers now
what's changed more than once is her
parentage and what I mean is that in the
early 1970s it was discovered that Wanda
was the daughter of two Golden Age
Marvel superheroes known as the wizard
and Miss America however this was
changed in the 1980s when it was
revealed that Wanda and her twin brother
Pietro better known as Quicksilver were
actually the children of magneto and his
former wife Magda now the story as it
went then was that after Magneto and
Magda's daughter dies in a house fire
and magneto seizes powers manifests for
the first time Magda leaves magneto and
flees to Mount wundagore
there she meets bova who was a cow that
was genetically modified into a cow
human hybrid by the High Evolutionary
and it turns out that Magnus pregnant
with twins and so after delivering the
twins Magda flees Mount wundagore
to avoid magneto finding her but dies of
exposure and so as fate would have it
Whizzer and Miss America were also at
Mount wundagore to deliver their baby
but unfortunately the child is
ultimately stillborn and Miss America
dies during childbirth
and so bova tells wizard that his wife
had died but has successfully delivered
twins which is kind of a dick move when
you think about it but he wants nothing
to do with the children and so Wanda and
Pietro are then taken in by a Romani
couple named Django and Maria maksimov
but Maria is eventually killed by an
angry mob and Wanda and Pietro escape
and basically raise themselves as they
travel throughout Europe but this was
changed again in 2014
actions event by Rick Remender and that
event lots of heroes are telepathically
inverted into villains and vice versa
and so when Wanda's inverted she becomes
evil and cast a spell that targets
everyone that shares a bloodline with
her but only Quicksilver is affected
meaning that while Wanda and Pietro are
siblings Magnus
was not their father and so what we
learned a bit later is that Django and
Maria are actually the biological
parents of Wanda and Pietro and they
were taken by the High Evolutionary who
altered their DNA and gave them back to
their parents
disguised as mutants and really the
whole reason for this change in their
origins lie in the movie rights to two
characters as at the time Disney had not
yet acquired Fox and Fox owned the movie
rights to the x-men and all the mutant
characters Disney though did want to use
the Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver in
Avengers age of Ultron and so to be able
to do that they changed their origin so
that there were no longer mutants and
while this change was almost universally
hated by fans it remains the status quo
as it relates to the origin of Scarlet
Witch although now that Disney owns Fox
who knows what we'll see in the future
but anyway with all that overly
convoluted origin out of the way we get
into scarlet witch's powers which
believe it or not have also been changed
multiple times during her earliest
appearances Scarlet Witch was said to
have quote-unquote hex powers but what
she could really do was not very well
defined and so basically she was able to
alter probabilities so that unlikely or
impossible events had a greater
likelihood of occurring now this power
manifested in a variety of ways from
things as simple as making a gun or
making all the support structures of a
building give way to more impressive
feats such as altering the radioactive
molecules within radioactive man so they
no longer emit energy now later when
Steve Englehart was writing The Avengers
Scarlet Witch began studying under
Agatha Harkness who trained Wanda in the
use of witchcraft and during the 1994
Scarlet Witch miniseries by Dan Abnett
and Andy landing Agatha discovers that
Wanda was a nexus being which means that
she serves as a hub of all magical
energy in the universe
now once Kurt Busiek took over as writer
of The Avengers in the 1990s he
introduced the idea that Wanda was
actually given the ability to wield
chaos magic by an elder god known as
C'thun so what all this means is that
Scarlet Witch is a very powerful wielder
of mystical energy and she's used her
powers as a sorceress to pull off some
pretty impressive feats going so far as
to be able to manipulate reality itself
for instance when Scarlet Witch wanted
to have children but couldn't because
she was married a vision and all she
simply used her mystical abilities to
make herself pregnant and give birth to
sons now in addition to creating life
Wanda can also resurrect the dead as she
did with another of her former love
interests a guy by the name
of wonder man but the most impressive
display of scarlet witch's powers came
at a time where she had undone yet
another change during Brian Michael
Bendis Avengers disassembled series that
scarlet witch's powers were not rooted
in Chaos magic at all but instead in
reality warping and it was surely after
this that we see scarlet witch's powers
no absolutely crazy but before we get
into that we have to highlight a couple
of things from Wanda's history first if
you recall the children that I mentioned
wanted creating what happened to them is
an important factor in Wanda becoming as
powerful as she did during this era and
so as it turns out the children Wanda
created were actually pieces of the soul
of a demonic entity named master
pandemonium and when he absorbed the
pieces of his soul back Wanda was left
childless but her mentor Agatha Harkness
removed her memories of the children to
spare her the mental anguish that comes
from losing children the other thing
that we have to remember is that Scarlet
Witch has never been a character that
would be described as stable and her
inability to control her powers is
actually what led to Okimoto to remove
her from consideration of the coming
earth sorcerer supreme at one point and
so with those things in mind what
happened during Avengers disassembled is
that Wanda realizes that the memories of
having children were missing and kills
Agatha Harkness for deceiving her and
then goes on to dr. doom for help in
returning them to her life and so to do
this dr. doom and Wanda used their
combined mystical forces to access the
lifeforce energy but the life force ends
up possessing Wanda and driving her
insane and so under the control of this
life force Wanda turns on the Avengers
and blows up the Avengers mansion using
the reanimated corpse of Jack of Hearts
which kills Scott Lang although he would
later be returned she then summons a
Kree warship which attacks the Avengers
killing Hawkeye now when the Avengers
are trying to find out who's responsible
for the attack that's when Doctor
Strange shows up and informs them that
there is no such thing as Chaos magic
and the scarlet witch's powers actually
allow her to manipulate reality but
basically like everything that we've
been talking about here this has also
been changed so the chaos magic actually
does exist but because of this attack
both the Avengers and the x-men start
considering the idea of killing Scarlet
Witch due to how powerful and unstable
she is and the danger she poses to
reality after Professor X tells them
that his telepathic abilities are not
strong enough to suppress her
reality-warping powers and so to prevent
this Quicksilver urges Scarlet Witch to
alter reality and so she takes the mind
of Charles Xavier Reed's
subconscious desires of everybody in the
world and then creates a new world known
as the House of M we're mutants dominate
humans Magneto's in charge of everything
and everyone subconsciously got what
they desired and so the fact that
Scarlet Witch is able to literally
rewrite reality and convince even
powerful characters like dr. strange
that is absolutely real shows us that
her reality-warping powers were
incredibly advanced but what made this
even more clear was when the House of M
reality ceases to exist and that magneto
kills Quicksilver after discovering that
he's behind his sister's manipulation of
reality and so after returning
Quicksilver life Wanda utters the words
no more mutants which causes 98% of the
world's mutant population to lose their
powers and while Scott at which his most
impressive feats do occur when her power
level is being amped by the life force
energy it does need to be pointed out
that her underlying status as a Nexus
being was the entire reason for why she
was able to channel that much power in
the first place now even after she was
purged of the lifeforce energy we see
one to perform some impressive feats
during the Avengers vs. x-men event such
as defeating Namor and magic each of
which were imbued with one-fifth of the
Phoenix force she was also able along
with hope to defeat Cyclops after he had
transformed into the Dark Phoenix and a
purge earth of the Phoenix force entity
now once the Phoenix was banished the
lights on cerebra began indicating
mutant life popping up once again
meaning that is detecting the presence
of new mutants thereby reversing the
effect of M day when she depowered most
of the mutant population but yeah one of
the other cool things that came out of
this was that after the Scarlet Witch
had taken the mutant populations powers
we actually found out that she had done
this not just in her universe but across
the multiverse in its entirety which is
one of the the fan theories at least a
fan theory that I've had for a long time
that the reason why there were no more
mutants born during the old man Logan
series is because of the Scarlet Witch
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain it make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rock for if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]